en principio le pregunto tanto petro
como hernández pueden ser considerados
populistas
yo creo que hay una buenas tardes la
diferencia fundamental me parece que en
el caso de rodolfo hernández es más un
demagogo de derecha
que se aprovecha de la incorrección
política tal como tú lo decías como en
el caso de bolsonaro y donald trump
cuando uno ve lo que dice la migración
cuando uno ve lo que dice de los
derechos humanos de la corrupción se
parece mucho pero si es un populista que
tiene un movimiento de masas que tiene
una trayectoria además en política pero
no entra del todo en el discurso anti
establecimiento porque de todas maneras
ha sido concejal con crisis está alcalde
de bogotá jefe de la oposición entonces
se trata de dos anti establecimientos
muy distintos uno populista y otro
demagogo hasta hace algún tiempo el
ingeniero rodolfo como él mismo se hace
llamar era una figura prácticamente
desconocida para gran parte de los
colombianos que significa que un
outsider como él llegue al balotaje
sin ello y con un movimiento con una
política en colombia ha sido
tradicionalmente conservadora el rol
fernández se instaló a punta de
extravagancias controversias como decía
hace un rato en corrupción política y
supone el fin de una larga era supone
además el desgaste el actual
establecimiento colombiana en el que
tiene muchísimo que ver la muy baja
aprobación que tiene y valdo que
entonces creo que por primera vez en los
últimos 30 años colombia tendrá que
elegir entre dos opciones que se
reivindican como anti establecimiento
cuáles son las posibilidades reales de
que hernández gane la presidencia y
cuáles son esas propuestas que hicieron
que casi seis millones de colombianos
votarán por él
en realidad no hay muchas propuestas
creo que la gente votó por un y talante
por un discurso y el discurso
básicamente tiene como dos elementos y
lucha a brazo partido contra la
corrupción y austeridad es decir que no
haya más despilfarro que esta va estar
más cerca de la gente pero en concreto
se estaba muy poco del programa el
cálculo de rol fernández cuales
básicamente sumar los votos del
unionismo que son contra petro sumar sus
votos y ahí que con esas matemáticas
llegarían a un millón es la única
posibilidad que tiene el petró de
contrarrestarlo es a petro le hacen
falta dos millones que los podría
obtener el de los aún muchos indicios
que quedan en colombia de esas 10
millones de personas que no votaron y
obviamente el centro que aunque ha
venido desapareciendo tiene 900.000
votos entonces que no pueda conquistar
el centro y si finalmente rodolfo
hernández termina por por recibir todos
los bordes del organismo creo que ambos
ambas dimensiones terminarán por
decantar la elección en colombia